new york police department will be led  by a woman for the first time in its  176-year history kishan sewol the nassau  county chief of detectives on long  island will be tapped for the job today  the 49 year old beat out candidates from  within the nypd and other departments  around the country incoming new york  city mayor eric adams said sewell is a  proven crime fighter and can deliver the  safety and justice new yorkers deserve a  really incredible story she grew up in a  housing project in queens and now is  going to lead the nation's largest  police force it's a good interview with  her in the paper this morning where she  says she's humbled but she's ready to  meet the moment that's right i love that  new yorkers are waiting for that moment  yes we are waiting that's awesome that  is awesome this is very cool story